I just know that there are people out
there who like spend their paychecks on
sneakers and they call themselves Fisher
it
this changes everything not being able
to see the brand don't what is this made
out of like r2d2 skin someone being on
the bball courts in like Space Jam this
is a white t-shirt of men's shoes
everyone has fun I see some like frat
boy wearing these I think I'm gonna go
with the basketball shoes just because
basketball shoes are always insanely
expensive I'm gonna guess that these are
120 dollars and that these are 240 I
think that these are Morison no no no no
I think that these are more expensive
because the bottom is completely clean
you have the patriarchy you get all the
power and then just to flaunt it you're
like we get to wear comfortable shoes
we're not gonna oh my god I want the
girl version of this shoe these are
awesome
I feel like these would be in like a
Missy Elliott video I don't know what
these are they look cool though
I'm jealous that men just get to wear
comfortable there's so much pink padding
in this these look exactly like the
basketball shoes I had in eighth grade
I'm not kidding I feel like these might
be like beefs or something I didn't get
your alyssum you're wrong I would say
these I would pay $175 for my feet not
to hurt all the time
is this a cool person shoe now this is
probably one of the lizard to go things
I've ever seen
well there's a shoe inside this boot
it's a shoe condom that's like a new hmm
I guess you do that right I don't
understand why men think women are
ridiculous when this kind of is floating
around I'm guessing these are expensive
just because they're really weird I'm
gonna say these are these more expensive
what do you give it one hundred seventy
five hundred eighty-five that can't be
right
Emmett the more expensive ones were ugly
around saying that's a lot of money and
I could have gotten like seven kittens
out of those pairs of shoes men are
weirder than women why would you spend
that much money on shoes that are not
your size that you cannot wear you're
not allowed to or it's gonna [ __ ] them
up
a brand is worth so much more than the
shoe oh my god says why not on the side
maybe these are Hilary Duff's Nikes it's
just so sad what's happening over there
oh yeah you don't know the half of it
you